en India los trabajos para levantar a
los escombros del accidente de tren
sucedido el viernes por la noche en el
estado de odicha continúan después de
que las autoridades dijeran que las
operaciones de búsqueda y rescate habían
concluido el Primer Ministro narendra
modi quien visitó el lugar el sábado
declaró que quienquiera que sea señalado
culpable recibir al castigo más estricto
entendemos que este tipo de
investigación debe realizarse de manera
rápida y Esperamos que en los próximos
15 o 20 días esté listo el informe
Este es el tercer accidente de tren más
mortífero de la historia de la India y
el peor en cuanto a números de
fallecidos desde 1995 se espera que
aumente el número de víctimas mortales
centenares de personas se reportaron
heridas muchas de ellas de gravedad
cuando se produjo el accidente el tren
Se incendió nadie pudo salvarse algunos
consiguieron salir otros huyeron las
cercanías del sitio de la tragedia se
transformó en un lugar de homenajes a
las víctimas con flores y velas
encendidas en memoria de ellas un
artista de arena esculpió en una playa
una obra que representa el accidente una
manera muy particular de abogar por la
pronta recuperación de los
sobrevivientes